so we were told since we since once we
lost the smell of the smell and taste
they say you just gotta isolate for
seven days if you don't need a hospital
bed we're not going to see you that
isolate but we were basically told act
as if you have it because we think you
do because of what the unique things
that happen to you but now that we're
past the time
now they're saying still be cautious
which kind of sucks like I said I would
not be on here saying that me and my
wife believed we had it and doctors we
talk to you if we didn't lose the smell
and taste that was our biggest indicator
yeah I know when I can't taste wine do
you think that's why so many people in
Italy realize they had it like like
nobody in England realize they had it
right like everybody's right but Italy
was like know there's a problem what is
these everybody stay inside stay inside
we can allow no other country locks down
immediately Italy's like alright
everybody inside for at least a month
let's just get this thing out of here
photo